[Music]
welcome to South Africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning good morning
didn't wanna drink hi it's your on five
o'clock here in South Africa and today
we're gonna show you just how beautiful
South Africa is we're gonna show you a
little bit of the wildlife right now yep
let's go on a safari trip okay what's
your name again
it would Edward
we stayed at the Kruger Park Lodge and
it is about a 20-minute drive to the
Kruger Park cruiser
alright guys were here at the entrance
gate in the Kruger National Park that's
our one over there
Kruger National Park is almost twenty
thousand square kilometers which is huge
a couple from the U is is joining us for
today's game drive here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
this is South Africa look at it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys so we came in here at this gate
at the Kruger National Park and we've
driven up to here skukuza which is one
of the biggest camps in the Kruger
National Park and we're gonna have some
lunch break now see just so you know the
Kruger Park is one of Africa's largest
game reserves it is as big as Israel and
it is slightly smaller than Belgium
which is huge
[Music]
this is an ostrich egg guys look at the
size of it between my head
yeah
got some coffee
[Music]
so much let's go
sadly the rhinos are still in danger of
extinction killed for their horns and
mostly sold in Asian countries like
China
[Music]
we want to ask please stop buying their
horns to save these amazing animals
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys I hope you enjoyed the
Safari ride but there's one thing
missing he posed so this is where we
staying at we're staying at one of these
buildings over here and close to here
there's hippos we call them sea Acquia
and I'm gonna show you just how close he
can be to them come on
[Music]
you alright guys we're here but we're a
little bit far away they ride over there
so we're gonna go in for a closer look
you guys ready yeah
[Music]
[Music]
he stayed here for a week and we came
here every single day to see them now
it's interesting to know that hippos are
considered the second largest land
[Music]
sadly hippos are also killed for their
teeth now they might look calm to you
but they are the world's deadliest land
mammal killing 500 people each year in
Africa hey guys so we hope you enjoyed
this while I took with us that we took
in South Africa see you in the next
video bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]